hablamos de economía y hacemos foco en
argentina un país que tiene un panorama
bastante complejo en esa materia para
conocer los detalles está con nosotros
en el estudio jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches que lo que pasa allí en
argentina bueno vamos a empezar con uno
de los grandes problemas que es la
inflación el último dato de julio mostró
un aumento ínter mensual del 7,4 por
ciento la cifra más alta en dos décadas
pero el dato anual o sea el aumento de
los últimos 12 meses se disparó al 71
por ciento ese país registra una de las
subidas de precios más altas en todo el
mundo aunque para muchos analistas la
inflación podría cerrar el año en torno
al 90 por ciento o incluso más si el
gobierno de alberto fernández no logra
frenar la inflación para entender el
aumento de los precios allí conversamos
con el economista miguel pues ya no
director de carta financiera le
preguntamos por qué subieron tanto los
precios en julio esto respondió se
impusieron determinadas restricciones a
las importaciones
que hicieron que el dólar tuviera un
salto muy grande
y esto además se
juntó con la renuncia de martín guzmán
entonces en julio vos tuviste un momento
en el cual el dólar pasó de 250 pesos a
330 y sumado a la incertidumbre acerca
de las importaciones
las importaciones lo que sucede es que
el gobierno le dice a los importadores
que le va a vender dólares pero recién
dentro de 180 días y al precio que esté
en esos dólares dentro de 180 días lo
cual es imposible de saber
y eso hace que los importadores tengan
que
subir los precios para cubrirse y poder
recomprar la mercadería el día que
vendan porque no saben estrictamente a
qué precio le va a vender el banco
central bueno los problemas múltiples
pero hay uno que llama la atención jorge
y es el cepo cambiario que es esto con
el cepo cambiario son restricciones a la
compra de una moneda de otro país esto
por el temor de que una demanda excesiva
pueda hacer que la moneda local se
depreció generando mucha más inflación
en julio argentina aumentó este cepo
para viajes y compras en el exterior es
decir que el cepo alcanza al consumo de
divisas para viajes y gastos con tarjeta
de crédito fuera de argentina esto
significa que a cada compra se le deberá
sumar un costo adicional del 45 por
ciento según nuestro invitado estas
medidas están afectando a la debilitada
economía
yo diría que toda la cuestión del cepo
cambiario está a mi entender muy cerca
de
de llegar a un fin por agotamiento
porque simplemente ha demostrado no
tener ningún tipo de
de éxito el banco central no tienen
reservas se están utilizando las los
depósitos del sistema
para aquellos que tienen acceso a los
dólares y la brecha pasa a ser superior
al
100% entonces con esta situación en mi
interpretación es que van a tener que
hacer una liberalización del tipo de
cambio aunque no lo quieran lo cual va a
suponer también un salto inflacionario
un salto en el nivel de precios pero
creo que es eso
correr seriamente el riesgo de no poder
terminar el mandato aquí hay otro
problema importante jorge y es la deuda
con el fm y constantemente tiene que ir
a negociaciones bueno y es que el recién
nombrado ministro de economía sergio
massa sostiene reuniones con el fmi
previo a la revisión periódica del
acuerdo de deuda de argentina por valor
de 44.000 millones de dólares la tercera
economía de américa latina lleva muchos
años gastando más de lo que logra
recaudar este déficit se ha convertido
en uno de sus principales problemas
macroeconómicos la meta de los últimos
ministros de economía ha sido
precisamente reducir al 2,5 por ciento
del producto interno bruto el déficit
fiscal primario pero la pregunta ahora
es esa meta es realista y esto dijo
nuestro invitado
no llego diría que no
para empezar hay que entender que el
grueso del esfuerzo se lo pasa a los
privados porque le hace subir las
tarifas
tarifas que tendrán subas entre el 200 y
el 400 por ciento pero además de eso
tenemos el problema del banco central el
problema del banco central es que
con la deuda que tiene que son las leaks
son letras del banco central que se
utilizan para justamente absorber la
emisión de pesos y que no tenga un
efecto inflacionario bueno eso significa
un déficit de 450 mil millones de pesos
por mes que eso probablemente no nos
tenga a ustedes no puedan tener
referencia pero el déficit del tesoro es
de 250 mil millones por mes con lo cual
es casi el doble del déficit del tesoro
es brutal
así que
realmente no
imagino cómo pueda cumplirse esa meta
del 25 %
yo diría que no hay forma de cumplirla
y además a riesgo que el fondo monetario
está tan atrapado como en argentina
porque está muy
está muy preocupado porque le presta a
la argentina más de lo que le debiera
haber prestado y acá estábamos muchas
gracias jorge es toda la economía a
continuación del debate